IF IT LEAKED FROESE LAB.
WE BEGINS HOURH A CRS
ROMENTENATONALD S A NOON THETIO
TO DEFY THFO PRESIDENT AND
CHOOSE TRUTHCC>> DO YOU THINK Y?
SOI PE BRIAN
EIKE SECO HS JUST THERE FOR TRI
BACKGROUND.I IEE.S POWE A MOTHE'
IESIUNLIKEO BECAUSE MITCH McCOW
HAVINGIPARTISAN  BEST BACK TONNL
WELL. IGATIOECTION MOST SENATE S
YOU C
REP
h VOTE?G YOUR MEMBERS TO OB?
>> I'VE MADE MY NAARD R L NN SC
CORRESPONDENT JAMIE GANGEL IIT.
ACCORDING TO REPUBLICAN G WHA
KS FAMILIAR WITH
CO PRESSURING REPUBLICAN SENATS.
BUT WE ARETHAT
24 HOUHAT  OUT TOR .ASGHT BE WA,
AND AS TO VOTE
COMM.
QUOTE, AS A PERSONAL FAVOR,
S NOT ECEDEN
T A LES
AND REPUBLICANS, I NEED THIS
TAKE R
E  THIS IS NOT ANY
TLY RIGH'S BUDE SOMEBODY GET C
AND  CAUGHT AT HISING THAT KINDA
REBL TO ,  NOINGEN,
EXTROF ASKING FOR A PERSON
THE SOURCE WENT ON TO CAN YOU H?
ISESD JOHNR SOURCES AR
SUCONNELL
MAY RELY CCETHAT MRS. 'SISITS
TOD SWAY SOME REPUBLICAN
WHEN SA WORRIED
, ANRT
SER S
SOMETHING T ENDA THAT
HAD HI>> Reporter: THROUGH COUN,
WEAT AT LEAST REPUBL
THAT,M OU 15 DECLINED TWITH HE.
AND ANOTHEBE
T REPLY. MEANS THAA RI OBLICANW
>> YOUWA
END, LET DOWN
WITH AEVIN
AL THEREK FEW MINUTES OFME
THAT DAYSENATOCO SAID THIT TO EV
AND IN SOMCASES, DIDO AT T
LIVES.D AT I FEESTRONGLY>> CNN
CA.TH THE LEADER THERE
HIM AG  GIVE YO
WH TT NOW,YOU LOOK EVERYTHING V
REPUBLICANY  BRE.  TRE LEADERS V
COIDHE
DEFEAIS.NNELL MADE HIS CASE
THE SCENES TELLIN
S BECATHEY
BELIEVS UL HELP  T
E'T
ARGUMENT, AN
PUBLICLY.
EN A
RN
EEG CLUDINE REPUBLICANAT
WHSA SHE W
N UNTIL MOMENT
SHELY MOORE TOI ASKED HER IF SHE
ARGUMENT IS WORKING AND ALSO
MRS. SICKNICK IS MEETING WITH
THS, SOMOFPLANNING TO VOTEKE
SUSALLINDICATINGEYL
MAKING HER CASCLEARLY AND
ND
PERSONAL TERMS ABOUT THEOSS
SHE EXPERIENCED OFER SON WHO
DEFENDED THE CAPITOL ON THAT
DAY, JANUARY.
ALL CONGRESS T THAT
AGAI BILL, VISIT M
SOGRAVE.
T ICANS SH, KEATOR RON
JOHNSON OF WIS, CAME OUT NT MEEL
THUTH, HE IDOT GOINGO
SO IT IS UNLIKELY TOWAY
I CAN  IN TALKTHREPUBLANTHEY
ARE CONFIDT THATWI IRD ABLY LOS
SEVEN POTENTIALLY, BUT THEY AR
CERTTH LOSTEN,
WHICH IS THEIC NUMBEHE.  MAW   O
GRNE"THEIL OFTEN ISHH OR COU
OR THAT VOTER.
I JUST WANT
I'M WRONG T MITCISNO FAN OF TRUD
HIM AFTER THE INSURRECTION, T 'T
POWEROFCKNICK, TH
BRAVTHEIAT
MOTHER DESERVES AN AR SHE'S
NOT GOG TO GET, ATINHEMISSION .A
MA WHAT.
HE CAN ACQUIESCEWHAT
WAUT THERE'S GOING TO ETE ANMEG
FTER TER LEARNED THAT LESSON.
>> THEY NEVER LEARN IT AND, YOUW
MITCH McCONNELL AND THE NDRE,
THG TO DO SOMETHING
WRONG LATER SOONE.
AND  A LESSON
BEA LONGJOD HA NOT -
AN OLL NOT
SEE HAPPE.
INSTE INTO
BENGHA?
TEN.
THERE WERE TENNVFIVE IN THE HOU.
OF FIVE,ASELEC
COMM
AND YOU KNOW W
AMERICAN, I HANO PROBL W
AT
I NTO OW
I WANTED TO GET TO THE BOTTO
I ENA POWER, WHICH I DON'T HAVET
S.
NOT WANTHIN ATTACK TO HY REPUBLU
WOON THE PEOPLE'S USS BE
BUT WE KNOW THE
SADLY, YOU KW,DENCFOTT
OVERWHELMINGEYCAUSE THEY DON'T N
E REPU
LEADER, TOHEREHILLARY CLINHA SWO
THEY DHIF OF STAFFTHER T DONALD
NECOTN
HAVEU DOING?
DID U E NATION
AR
DID YOAL THE RIO
SEEMED TO CA MOR
THE TRUTUL
CALLY.
ONG THALEXING
ITS  THEAY THAT THIS STRUCTURED,
BE MORAN TOU
WILL LIKELT IF
THE USE SPEAKER, MOVES FORWARD
WITHETE A SELECT
SELECCO
NDS
E DEMOCRATS ARE  HAVE CONTROL O
EQUALLY AS BAD OF A PROBLEM FORA